bonsoir bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale préparé par la rédaction de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 10 février voici
les titres
le football-club de versailles en demi
finale de la coupe de france les
yvelinois ont battu bergerac hier la
rencontre qui se jouait à périgueux
s'est décidée aux tirs au but c'est
seulement la cinquième fois dans
l'histoire qu'une équipe de 4e division
atteint le dernier carré de la
compétition
le prochain adversaire est connue elle
sera gros les versaillais recevront
l'ogcnice le 2 mars pour jouer leur
place en finale le troisième de ligue 1
a éliminé notamment le paris saint
germain et marseille dans les tours
précédents un match qui devrait bien se
disputer en région parisienne reste à
savoir dans quel stade et puis une
cinquantaine de supporters locaux a fait
le déplacement à périgueux pour soutenir
leurs joueurs et dans le même temps
mille personnes ont assisté à la
rencontre sur écran géant place du
marché à versailles immersion dans cette
journée historique
ces images pour commencer le retour dans
la cité royale des joueurs du fc
versailles c'était cet après midi une
vingtaine de supporters sont venus
accueillir leurs héros au stade mont
boron la veille les hommes de youssef
chebbi et youcha youssef chibi marqué
l'histoire une qualification en demi
finale de la coupe de france le fcv 78 a
disposé de bergerac au terme d'une
séance de tirs au but un partout après
le temps réglementaire 5 4 aux tirs aux
buts un exploit puisque c'est seulement
la cinquième fois dans l'histoire qu'un
pensionnaire de nationale 2 la quatrième
division accède aux demi finales une
fierté du côté des supporters mais aussi
des joueurs écoutez ces réactions
collectées par mathilde au front quand
j'allais les voir il hier au stade dans
cabaye cup est donc là cherchent à les
voir revenir bref ester pour pour eux
revoir cette ambiance qu'on a eu on a eu
hier c'est super sympa c'est super sympa
de voir qu'on est soutenue suivie et
appréciée par par notre ville et de
rentrer comme ça en vainqueur c'est
agréable montrer le soutien dans le
final c'est qu'on veut faire et puis
leur dire que la demi finale bat et là
et qu'on va essayer de la gagner quoi
même la finale ça fait plaisir ça fait
plaisir donc en on voit qu'on a fait
plaisir aux gens voilà que qu'on ait
soutenu voilà donc il y avait trois
quatre personnes vient est toujours là
il y en a un peu plus bon on va pas en
avoir plus pour aller décrocher du final
on sait jamais at elle l a fait en même
temps je pense qu'on a tous un peu sur
un nuage et on redescend tranquillement
[Applaudissements]
voilà la fête qui s'est poursuivie avec
cette joie des versaillais avec mon
plateau miquel et demi d'euros bonjour
bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78 il est
18 heures c'est déjà le soir alors on va
tout d'abord revenir avec vous sur
wii on a très peu dormi cette nuit on va
revenir sur notre journée historique
avec les supporters de versailles donc
on est dans cette édition spéciale est
d'abord on va revenir quand même sur les
faits la rencontre alors c'était
vraiment le match piège par excellence
un match contre une équipe de national 2
sur un terrain non homologué mais qui a
obtenu une dérogation à la dernière
minute ce bergerac avait en plus à son
tableau de chasse des équipes de ligue 1
comme metz ou saint-etienne sur ce stade
de périgueux autant dire que la tâche
s'annonçait rude pour les versailles et
dé versailles et qui ne se sont pas
laissé impressionner par le contexte à
la 14e minute il a à dire à souba marque
ce but magnifique sur une passe de capot
silva magnifique but pour un joueur qui
n'a pas souvent l'occasion de
s'illustrer dans l'exercice il avait
seulement marqué un but dans le
championnat de nationale 2 1 0 ce sera
le score à la pause mais les joueurs de
versailles se font peur et se font
égalisé à la 90e minute un but signé
axel très sens à ce moment là on s'est
dit gregory que ce serait très compliqué
on n'y croyait plus mais eux ici j'aime
cruel c'est versailles en a eu très peur
et finalement les versets l'ont emporté
5 tirs au but à 4 sur le terrain des
berges hors de péril bergerac par à
périgueux s'était d'après tir au but
manqué par lingua l'entraîneur youssef
chibi nous décrypte cette rencontre
c'est un match difficile face à une
bonne équipe avec un socle solide
défensif on a réussi à
des jouets se plante en marquant assez
tôt ça reste un avantage très important
face à ce genre d'équipé mais on a
manqué justement de lucidité sur une ou
deux situations pour pouvoir tenir le
score jusqu'au bout mais bon derrière
les garçons ont réussi à se concentrer
et s'approprier cette séance de pénalty
alors sur cette séance de tirs au but
les versets qui n'ont pas douté malgré
l'égalisation en fin de match on écoute
le défenseur walid diouf dès que le
match et l'infini on a pris un but mais
il ya quatre-vingts minutes ou plus on
savait sinon c'est une possibilité on
est parti avec confiance tout mon ami
c'est penalty on a eu la chance que un
genre de bergerac tir sur le poteau et
ça nous assurait aujourd'hui donc très
content cette victoire a procuré
évidemment énormément de plaisir aux
joueurs qui réalisent un véritable
exploit puisque c'est seulement la
cinquième fois de l'histoire de la coupe
de france c'est un club de 4e division
rejoint les demi finales vous l'avez dit
gregory versailles rejoint les équipes
comme calais où quevilly on écoute
youssef chebbi une fierté forcément une
fierté une pensée pour mes joueurs parce
qu'ils se sont ils se sont dépensés ils
se sont surpassés enfin c'est dans un
contexte où être une région contre nous
des responsabilités on représente la
région parisienne désormais donc c'est
une vraie fierté pour nous et cette
victoire procure également énormément de
plaisir aux supporters ils étaient
plusieurs milliers à versailles à suivre
cette rencontre sur écran géant et on a
la chance d'avoir avec nous à michael
par écran interposé visioconférence le
buteur de cette rencontre il avait
ouvert le score vous l'avez dit
versailles s'est fait rejoindre au score
c'est in that diarrassouba bonsoir hills
a
mis le terrain dans ce club du fc
versailles 78 déjà bravo à vous comment
vous sentez-vous justement au lendemain
de de cet exploit on peut l'appeler
exploit puisque vous êtes en demi finale
on imagine que la nuit a été courte
déjà on n'a pas beaucoup dormi que vous
avez vu la nuit a été courte et frouard
où un rêve qui ne veut pas et ne pas
terminer en fait j'ai pas envie de me
renier parce que là j'ai l'impression
d'être dans un rêve et
c'est de bonne augure pour la suite
pourvoir en demi finale aux cultures de
l'adversaire et wafa ces emplois
pourquoi pas parce que son convoi où
l'engouement qu'ont pu
transmettre autour de nous ben ça fait
super plaisir et ça nous encourage
encore plus
c'est une joie incroyable plus qu'un
match finalement avant la finale là vous
êtes vraiment dans les la dernière ligne
droite
dans le dernier carré on s'imaginait pas
et franchement c'est déjà un exploit est
arrivé ici sachant qu'il ya des équipes
pour le paris saint germain qui sont
sortis qui les a incités à voter
marseille
et non franchement c'est beau mais c'est
par envie de continuer l'aventuré à
l'est
racontez nous les émotions au moment du
but très joli but le disait michel on a
pu le voir à l'image c'était au quart
d'heure de jeu qu'est ce que vous avez
ressenti à ce moment là au moins de
l'ouverture du score
on est là parce nous dit ben on est
vraiment en ce soir dans un match de
coupe pour une place en demi finale donc
ma
avec la magie de la coupe chèrement
peut-être qu'à voir entrer et j'ai la
chance en fait un rebond qui surprend le
gardien et à ce moment là j'y croyais
moi en fait j'ai marqué trois événements
et des couches 6 dinars mais je pense
qu'elle est rentrée je crois et c'est là
que vous avez je commence à mettre trois
points de vie tellement j'avais pourquoi
faire comme si les mots ratio mais parce
que j'ai marqué mais franchement
c'est un travail collectif de l'équipe
tout ça oui
souligny
les remercier nos supporters
mitchell je précise que c'est le
deuxième but de la saison
en championnat et du coup on a un but
qui compte on l'a compris dans cette
compétition et en plus en quarts de
finale justement l'égalisation de
bergerac qui est venu un peu on va dire
contredire les plans pendant on va dire
une période temporaire de versailles on
se pose la question comment vous avez
fait pour ne pas sombrer à ce moment là
du match parce qu'il restait quatre
minutes de temps additionnel et les tirs
aux buts derrière on pourrait on a pu
craindre ni quel que que versailles sont
bruns finalement et surtout au niveau du
public grégory le public commençait à à
chambrer a vraiment fortement les
joueurs versailles est également les
supporters à versailles qui étaient
présents du coup on s'est dit peut-être
que l'impact psychologique avait tourné
en la faveur de bergerac c'est souvent
comme ça donc ce type de situation il a
fallu être fort dans la tête isa à ce
moment là
[Musique]
et là maintenant je me dis je voyage est
à peu près avec les personnages me le
dit doit rester quatre belles minutes je
mets 10 et les supporters franchement
les ont poussés parce que à ce moment là
le stade il a tremblé et c'était
franchement une émotion que l'on ne peut
pas expliquer et là je me retourne vers
son gardien ban est il dit il n'atteint
kg est pas c'est pour nous et pour moi
après je dis comment ça c'est pourquoi
moi je pensais qu'ils parlaient du but
j'ai dit comment ça une dînette inquiète
pas la séance de tirs au but c'est pour
moi et là quand j'ai vu la détermination
dans son regard vous réponds moment j'ai
vu mes autres coéquipiers à côté je leur
ai dit qu'ils les gars les gars ont valu
aux tirs au but on va faire confiance à
dan nous on a juste à se concentrer sur
nos tirs au but eh ben il va en sortir
un voire deux ni trois boulots et c'est
comme ça qu'on a inversé plus ou moins
là là là pendant son état psychologique
et la victoire 5-4 aux tirs au but on le
rappelle un partout au terme du temps
réglementaire désormais la prochaine
échéance ids assez le 2 mars prochain ce
sera la demi-finale contre l'ogcnice
d'ailleurs c'est didier deschamps pour
la petite anecdote qui fait le tirage au
sort un cas procéder à ce tirage au
centre sélectionneur de l'équipe de
france vous avez tiré le troisième de
ligue 1 qui a sorti en plus le paris
saint germain lors du 16e de finale
marseille nancy en 8e de finale
marseille en quarts de finale victoire 4
buts à 1 sur sur ce tour précédent un
club de ligue 1 face à vos envies de se
dire enfin enfin ton versailles
on se dira enfin et on ne tarde jamais
et du coup ça nous fait plaisir de
rencontrer en demi finale car on se dit
voilà enfin un club de ligue 1 on a
réellement plus rien à faire ça veut
dire on se dit qu'on a à
90 minutes voire plus d'aller pratiquer
mais on est à un match de la finale de
france du coup on se dit prête avec la
magie noire qui peut se passer
tout est possible on peut se passer
réunion tout est possible franchement on
y croit on y croit sachant qu'on les
respecte bien sûr on a vu comme vous
allez disons sortie par le haut en bas
et de sortie marseille cherche un
repreneur le connaissant restockage chez
elle par rapport à son précédent pas
vide et c'est franchement on sait que ça
va être super dur mais on a confiance en
nous et surtout on a confiance en nos
supporters qui on a vu on a vu qu'ils
nous soutiennent mais on espère une sont
de plus en plus nombreux pour lâcher non
plus si un élan de sympathie qui qui
s'est emparée de votre équipe de cette
équipe versailles et dominique l ouïe
très rapidement nice justement pour pour
revenir sur les statistiques de nice
c'est un bilan championnat qui est très
bon il son troisième bilan de 13
victoires pour quatre nuls et 6 défaites
ils sont du coup toujours en course pour
cette coupe de france et ce titre en fin
de saison ils sont coachés par
christophe galtier à isal de 10,1 à
l'instant qui est peut-être en ce moment
même le meilleur coach de la ligue 1
seul point lors peut-être à exploiter
pour les versailles et ils sont habitués
à perdre des matches supposé facile
contre des équipes de bas de classement
ils ont notamment perdu contre
clairement récemment donc peut-être que
ça pour réaliser les versailles et sur
cette rencontre avec cette magie de la
coupe de france 1 tout est possible ids
le dit d'ailleurs mathilde francou à
questionner quelques-uns de vos
coéquipiers c'était tout à l'heure lors
de votre retour de périgueux c'est un
super tirage façon ce n'est voilà encore
que des gros tirages donc on ne peut
être que satisfait on va préparer ça
tranquillement un peu plus tard par son
arrivée à ce stade la compétition c'est
très bien quand on tombe sur des grosses
équipes mais je pense que c'était
l'équipe la plus redoutable qui restant
en lice et ben voilà enfin lancer sa
défaire maintenant
sur un an bien mettre 4 à l'om donc on
peut pas l'être mais mais quoi qu'il
arrive on va jouer avec nos armes et on
va essayer de faire quelque chose de
grand et hier avec lequel on aura
l'occasion d'en parler tout à l'heure on
était dans le bus des supporters
versailles et nous avons vécu en direct
ce tirage au sort et on a pu aussi posé
les quelques questions et obtenir les
réactions des supporters regarder si
bien sûr c'est faisable c'est football
c'est la magie c'est la magie du
football
tout est possible dans le sport donc je
dirais pourquoi pas après bon le match
va se disputer début mars on espère que
du côté niçois ils prennent un peu ce
match à la légère
qui se concentre un peu plus sur le
championnat enfin comme de ligue 1 après
tout est possible dans le sport mais on
a une très belle équipe aussi faut pas
l'oublier on n'est pas là par hasard il
ya une solution qui émerge un peu sur
les réseaux sociaux même des groupes de
supporters parisiens la prônent c'est de
jouer peut-être au parc des princes ce
serait un rêve pour toi bah alors le
parc des princes versailles au parc des
princes ce serait assez énorme ce serait
aller les rois et les marquis chez les
princes donc voilà ça ce serait sympa la
métaphore est toute trouvée de paul
supporters versailles oui parce que
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose aujourd'hui michael on sait que
cette demi finale se jouera le 2 mars
c'est vers ça et qui recevra l'ogcnice
mais quoi qu'il arrive ce ne sera pas au
stade mon bon non effectivement on sait
bien le stade mort on ne peut pas
accueillir de tels événements à cause
d'un problème d'éclairage car on ne doit
pas voir de sources lumineuses depuis la
chambre du roi soleil qui est à peu près
à un kilomètre à peu près du château de
versailles donc impossible de dire
d'allumer tout simplement les des
projecteurs pour pouvoir jouer au
football en nocturne et c'est une ces
sites une règle qui date de trois
siècles donc trois siècles après la mort
de louis xiv ça existe encore une mesure
des architectes des bâtiments de france
5 une mesure qui a la dent dure on peut
le dire alors la rencontre devrait quand
même se tenir en région parisienne dans
une enceinte en capacité de recevoir un
tel événement les dirigeants versaillais
travaillent déjà sur le dossier jean luc
arribart le directeur général du club a
confirmé que trois pistes se dégageait
le parc des princes 1 qui est l'antre du
paris saint-germain 48 mille places
environ le club de la capitale il doit y
disputer encore huit matches de
championnat sans compter la ligue des
champions et les quelques matchs aussi
du psg féminin il ya aussi le stade
charléty capacité de 20000 places l
enceinte du paris fc club de ligue 2
c'est là d'ailleurs que des incidents
avaient éclaté à lors du match de coupe
de france entre le paris fc et
l'olympique lyonnais les deux équipes
avaient d'ailleurs été éliminées sur
tapis vert de la coupe de france enfin
le stade de france plus de 80000 places
qui accueille régulièrement la sélection
française l'équipe de france de football
et c'est aussi dans ce stade qu aura
lieu la finale de la coupe de france le
mi mai prochain avec un coût de location
on imagine assez élevé d'ailleurs un
petit tweet à c'est assez drôle avons
partagé qui a été
ébruitée par par le fc versailles c'est
mieux de le faire en public non coupé g
inside tué à la place si tu as de la
place au parc des princes d'élus mars
c'est pour des amis voilà on essaye de
pousser côté versaillais pour cette
solution du du parc des princes est ce
que vous avez une préférence il avoue le
parc des princes a fait rêver et
forcément oui clairement clairement moi
personnellement
après le stade de france en va aussi
du coup
je suis supporter du paris saint germain
depuis tout petit du coup ce sera un
rêve de pouvoir affronter une équipe de
ligue 1 disputés en plus troisième de
ligue 1 actuellement et dans le stade
la jouer aux sports de versailles nous a
tout à leur dire c'est mathilde francou
qui s'est entretenu avec lui c'est
nicolas fouquet nous a dit que peut-être
la solution charléty malheureusement
semblait privilégiée donc on verra
peut-être aussi le rêve par des princes
se confirme on l'espère pour vous en
tout cas une zaoui vous êtes plutôt
confiant ce sera la dernière question
sur l'issue d'une solution que le club
puisse trouver une solution et qu'on ne
se retrouve pas dans la situation du
tour de deux toulousains s'étaient en
huitièmes de finale où la rencontre a
été inversée vous êtes allés jouer à
toulouse finalement alors que versailles
devait recevoir le match à la base bah
j'espère qu'on trouvera une solution ne
sera pas qu'on nous avait dit et là j'ai
confiance en
dirigeant qui pose pour faire le
nécessaire pour qu'on puisse jouer déjà
en région par exemple lorsqu'elles chaud
surtout pas l'oublier on est encore deux
derniers représentants
parisiens et amateurs
et du j'espère que rapport à ça on
trouverait une solution
sage aider
pour porter haut les couleurs
franciliennes la rencontre est prévue le
2 mars on le rappelle merci nwosa et
bravo encore à vous pour ce parcours on
espère que qui va se poursuivre en coupe
de france merci
merci à vous un homme qui est forcément
heureux michael on imagine aussi suite à
cette qualification et qui avaient fait
le déplacement à périgueux on l'a croisé
juste avant le match c'est le maire de
versailles françois de mazières qui a
réagi à notre micro c'est important
aussi d'être là témoigner que voilà la
ville est à leurs côtés c'est une
aventure collective qui vivent assez
extraordinaire et donc la ville est
vraiment totalement avec une ambiance
folle mais c'était 95%
participants ils étaient pour et quand
j'ai 95 et des gens qui s 99 % étaient
pour revers gens mais alors nicolas
avait sa trompette et je sais pas si
vous avez entendu mais chaque fois
qu'ils avaient une chose qui était bonne
pour l'équipe de versailles vous
entendez à tromper au départ et
supporters il n'avait pas compris donc
qu'ils applaudissent est aussi ils ont
commencé à comprendre que la rivière un
lien particulier entre la trompette et
les succès habile de versailles il
applaudissait plus à la fin
et côté petit didier baichère est
également avec nous en plateau bonsoir
mon sens député de la première
circonscription des yvelines qui
enveloppent justement une partie de la
ville de versailles on va parler avec
vous dans un instant d'un autre sujet
mais on profite de vous avoir un plateau
pour vous faire réagir versailles en
demi finale de la coupe de france quelle
est la réaction c'est magique c'est
assez extraordinaire j'ai suivi j'avais
une réunion publique donc j'ai suivi le
live tweet du club qui était assez
extraordinaire et celui de tv fils
maintenance et ses garçons ils sont
vraiment ils sont vraiment fantastiques
là franchement la nouvelle équipe
dirigeante fait aussi un super boulot
avec le club donc pas ce prix 80 stades
pour que l'équipe se développent et moi
que c'est que du plaisir maintenant
franchement voilà ici on demi finale
j'espère qu'ils vont lâcher prise pour
profiter et puis alors si c'est le parc
des princes franchement ils vont
profiter son souviendront de ce nazi
c'est la cerise sur le gâteau est
extraordinaire vraiment très très belle
équipe sur cette rencontre dont
versailles non non ne faisons aucun avis
fille je n'ai pas envie électeurs de
versailles non mais je pense qu'ils ont
ils ont une forme de pression il faut
pas qu'ils se la met plus que sa
demi-finale franchement pour versailles
moi j'espère en profiter parce que même
charléty sensu bon c'est plus un stade
de rugby
mais ça peut être qu'un bon moment on
peut tous être là en région parisienne
donc dans la région vraiment qu'ils
profitent et qui qui se souviennent de
toute leur vie de cette très belle
demi-finale ici le miracle arrive parce
que franchement ils ont une équipe qui
est très soudée il ya une vrai que la
très bonne ambiance entre les joueurs
donc alors là le stade de france ce coup
ci pour la finale on attendra pour le
stade de france merci didier deschamps
on retrouve tout à l'heure devant dans
le journal de la rédaction un journal
d'information locale or michael pour
terminer cette partie dédiée au football
club de versailles on a eu la chance
tous les deux de vivre ce succès
versailles et de l'intérieur on a suivi
les supporters marseillais dans ce
déplacement à périgueux oui tout à fait
en s'élever à assez tôt on a commencé à
9h30 et on les a suivis âgées tout au
long de leur périple jusqu'au retour le
lendemain matin on peut le dire à 4
heures du matin ont regardé la séquence
nous allons suivre le déplacement à des
supporters de versailles jusqu'à
périgueux pour le quart de finale entre
bergerac et versailles un périple de 600
km et ils sont motivés
[Applaudissements]
venez on va les sites edf
oh oui
ça fait donc trois heures et demie que
les supporters versailles sont partis
depuis un versailles avait coté à
anthony alors anthony comment ça se
passe du coup ce déplacement bah ça se
passe plutôt bien c'est une ambiance bon
enfant en joue et moi on vient à un
moment magnifique parce que des moments
comme ça on a envie de rap a peut-être
pas plu du tout on sait pas on espère
qu'on en verra d'autres mais faut
profiter il faut prendre à fond tout ce
qu'on a là maintenant et en profiter un
max en trois ans en club ça fait ça vous
fait quoi de voir à versailles à ce
niveau là la compétition j'ai déjà vécu
une partie parce que quand on a battu
dijon une fois en huitièmes de finale
jeu mais bon là c'est un rêve là c'est
vraiment quelque chose de sensationnel
[Applaudissements]
on est arrivé à périgueux après sept
heures de route donc on n'est pas venu
pour rien on est venu pour marquer un
maximum de buts là aujourd'hui ya le roi
soleil qui avec nous il va peut nous
porter chance et on espère se qualifier
et récupérer le trône
[Musique]
après 14 minutes de jeu versailles ouvre
le score par in that diarrassouba à 0
pour les joueurs de la cité royale
[Musique]
au même moment explosion de joie devant
l'écran géant installé place du marché à
versailles
1 0 ce sera le score à la pause
ouais c'est bien ça joue bien et ses
buts a fait beaucoup de bien aux à
versailles et surtout il des fournées
très bien y avoir un très bon pressing
on arrivait à
faire un bloc contre le supporter je
pense qu'on avait on a bien joué cette
première mi temps et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais la fête est gâchée à la 90e minute
at récent seule marque et égalise pour
bergerac
[Applaudissements]
les deux équipes vont devoir se
départager dans une terrible séance de
tirs au but il ne reste plus qu'une
chose c'est les avoirs aux penaltys et à
plus de ça je me tape tourné le dos là
un peu stressé quoi
ça versailles aussi les milliers de
supporters des joueurs de la cité royale
vont stresser jusqu'au bout font
après trois tirs au but réussis de
chaque côté à bergerac manque ce penalty
en tirant sur le poteau de diouf marque
le but libérateur
pour la première fois de son histoire
versailles se qualifie pour les demi
finales de la coupe de france c'est une
grande fierté d'avoir un club qui fait
un tel exploit pour tous notre ville
c'est vers son passé historique c'est
magique c'est énorme versailles club de
nationale 2 sera en demi finale de coupe
de france la belle aventure continue
ça y est assez faire un versailles temps
demi finale de la coupe de france ils
viennent de battre tirs au but bergerac
ici à périgueux dans une ambiance
fantastique
tu connais des versailles aura justement
née à les rencontrer ils sont fous parce
qu ils communient avec les joueurs en ce
moment alors c'était comment ce match
sera comme vous voyez c'est la famille
obama avant les autres faut-il porter
notre fidèle supporter at il ajouté
qu'est ce que je dis victor tirs au but
victoire aux tirs au but ouais bon lien
dmi on est en demies on est en demies ya
plus de voir c'est super on a gagné on a
gagné en en 2001 j'ai plus de fois j'ai
vu deux voix et on gagne ou on gagne
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
puis c'est pas une récompense c'est une
joie pour le club entier c'est pas vrai
qu'on prend on les a eus c'est ça qui
compte on est trop souvent très bien
c'est qu'on va pas dormir la nuit on va
fêter z toute la nuit et là bas c'est
incroyable et encadreurs prochain en
belgique au final on décrochera la
troupe c'est sûr
c'est mission accomplie mission
accomplie pour pour les joueurs pour le
staff et pour les supporters voilà il
est bientôt de 4h30 du matin et tout le
monde tout le monde est heureux de cette
qualif tout le monde est heureux aussi
de rentrer se coucher je crois et on
espère qu'il y aura de plus en plus de
monde à à montmoreau pour soutenir
l'équipe on l'a eue michael un retour
après 4 heures du matin ça pique un peu
à 18h face et mais en tout cas on a vécu
un moment historique tous les deux au
côté des supporters de versailles on
remercie les supporters de versailles de
nous avoir accueillis dans leur bus on
remercie anthony le président du de
l'association du club de versailles et
je pense qu'on s'en souviendra longtemps
on espère que le rêve va se poursuivre à
très très beaux moments et on va en
prendre rendez vous pour les
demi-finales peut être on va prendre
place dans le car on va passer dans le
car pour aller dans une enceinte
parisienne on verra quel est ce sera le
2 mars voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire
actualité le football-club de versailles
en demi finale de la coupe de france de
football victoire contre bergerac hier
prochaine adversaire on le disait
l'ogcnice que versa et recevra le 2 mars
pour jouer sa place en finale à un match
qui devrait bien se disputer en région
parisienne reste à savoir dans quel
stade le stade charléty le parc des
princes et le stade de france sont les
pistes évoquées merci michael d'avoir
été avec moi pour cet invité merci à
toutes et à tous de nous avoir suivi
l'édition spéciale qui touche à sa fin
et dans un instant retrouvez le 7-8
journal pour le reste d actualité
yvelinoise belle soirée que sur tv 78
[Musique]